in this series I'm going to surprise you
I'm going to strip away all the
complexity and hard graft and teach you
how to cook amazing food standing on
your head that is amazing incredibly
tender from the kitchen novice to the
buing chef going to give you the
confidence the recipes and the inside of
knowledge to make you a much better cook
slice around wasting
nothing I made my name cooking some of
the world's most demanding kitchens V
that's nice you make the V before
service yeah in my restaurants I expect
Perfection every PL has to be worthy of
a Michelin star and every time you make
it taste it as well everyday changes
here now I'm going to show you some
simple and accessible recipes for
fantastic food that you can cook easily
at home incredible I'll be holding you
by the hand it's getting better and
better and better teaching you
everything from how to cook on a budget
to bacon real fast food and my ultimate
feast recipes this is the only cookery
course you'll ever need
[Music]
Welcome to My ultimate cookery course
packed with cooking tips information and
100 recipes to take your life on right
now it's all about cooking with
chili for me chilies are an incredible
ingredient in the cooks Arsenal capable
of transforming dishes adding excitement
heat and a wonderful taste I'm going to
show you how to get the grips with their
intense flavor first up red mullet with
sweet chili sauce cooking is about being
ADV venturous and having the confidence
to go off peie and being a little bit
more daring so when you start combining
peanuts chili flakes and this amazing
fish red mullet trust me you're in for
an amazing
treat we're going to make a really nice
light sweet chili sauce first off your
chili off with the top in
half and those seeds inside are very
powerful incredibly hot
but full of flavor garlic two cloves of
garlic slice the garlic nice and thin so
it helps to puree the chilies in the
pest and water garlic in touch of salt a
little touch of sugar
in and then start
grinding push down
first the salt and the sugar really
helps the puree the chili
and the
garlic fish sauce always a base to a
chili sauce 2 tablespoons in and a touch
of rice wine vinegar fish sauce gives it
the saltiness the vinegar gives it a
nice acidic Wake Up 3
tablespoons of olive
oil
nice mix that up beautiful look at it
the colors incredible now spring onions
I want the
texture and the crunch spring onions in
the coriander slice it
once in fresh lime and that goes
brilliantly with a red mullet just
really wakes up the chili the garlic and
reminds the sauce that we're serving
with fish now
[Music]
taste wow it's delicious look at
that beautiful the longer that ch sauce
sits there the better it gets now for
the peanuts and chili that's going to
coat the top of the red
mullet peanuts in
salt in that helps to really grind the
peanuts down some beautiful dried chili
flakes creates a nice sort of warm heat
I'm using fresh chili for the sauce but
dried chili flakes for the coating which
will really crunch up when cooking just
a little bit of the coriander mix the
coriander in to the peanuts and look I
like them quite textured I don't want
them too small as a powder otherwise
they'll burn but crushed lightly to coat
the fish with the chili and peanut
seasoning in a separate Bowl beat two
eggs along with a splash of fish sauce
take your fillet lay in your red
mullet dip it in shake up your
peanuts and then in and make sure you
push that down cover that red
mullet up
beautiful
now make sure that Pan's really nice and
piping hot if you put the fish in and
the Pan's cold all those wonderful
peanuts and chili is just going to slide
off the fish so we need to sear it in
and get it nice and crisp in and lay
away from
you
[Music]
beautiful if the pan starts getting a
little bit too hot get your olive oil
and just Place Another teaspoon of olive
oil around the outside so it starts to
heat up as it hits the center and it
really helps you to stay so much more in
control and
turn nice and
gently they want that nice sort of
toasted sauteed crispness which adds A
really lovely flavor tilt the pan and
just base the top of the red mullet with
that really nice piping hot olive oil
you got that really nice roasted Crunch
and it goes brilliantly with that soft
sweetness of that fish inside gas off
and just leave them sitting in there and
finish with lime and just go over each
one now we take them
out and the sauce a touch on the bottom
on the tail of each
fish now to round that off serving some
fragrant rice soty
broccoli amazing and there you have a
delicious
peanut and crusted red mullet with a
wonderful sweet chili sauce cooking with
chilies isn't all about blow your head
off heat this dish uses the exciting
Taste of a chili but has a deliciously
elegant and subtle
flavor as you become more confident
using chilies you'll find they can
transform your cooking chilies are a
great way of making dishes exciting and
vibrant here are three quick recipes
that are full of flavor and come with a
kick
first up pasta with tomatoes an chies
and
[Music]
chilies for the spicy sauce slice
Anchovies and
garlic next dried chilies great for
keeping in the cupboard to add a hit of
heat on
demand then add the ancho oil to a hot
pan and Fry the chopped ingredients
add half cherry
tomatoes chopped black olives and salty
Capers cook to combine the
flavors in a separate pan bow dried
spaghetti another great store covered
staple when the pasta is tender but
still firm drain add to the sauce with a
splash of the water it's full of starch
which gives a great silky
consistency then season with pepper and
top with
Basel packed with big bold flavors and
ready in under 20 minutes pass with
tomatoes an chubby and
chilies my next deliciously different
chili recipe is grilled corn with
Chipotle chili
[Music]
butter first the topping chopped
coriander then add softened butter
soaked Chipotle chilies in hot water
these are dried jalapenos which have an
amazing Smoky
flavor drain and
[Music]
Cho mix together and
season next fry corn on the cup in olive
oil you want a really wonderfully
charred
flavor when colored add water to steam
through
to eat smother the cobs in the butter
and crumble over Lanas your
cheese fantastically messy to eat
grilled corn with Chipotle chili butter
an utterly delicious Smoky
treat my final recipe is a chili
classic jerk
[Music]
chicken start by making the intense jerk
marinade first Scotch bonnet chilies
they may be small but pack real heat and
a fruity
punch then chopped
garlic and fresh
[Music]
thyme for spice add ground cloves
cinnamon
nutmeg and all
[Music]
spice season with salt and pepper and
combine with olive
oil next score chicken legs so the hot
spicy flavors get deep inside the
meat rub thoroughly with the jerk mix
and
marinade add olive oil to a hot
dish Brown the marinated chicken for 10
minutes then add wor
[Music]
sauce cover and cook in the oven at 220°
for 20
minutes
[Music]
hot spicy jerk chicken easy to make and
Finger Licking
Good three different chilies three
amazing flavors three irresistible
dishes
nice next five more of my 100 tips that
will make your life easier in the
kitchen first up how to deed chili to
get the seeds out hold it up right and
just rub the chili between your hands
the seeds are incredibly hot you're just
releasing them from the
inside tapping it down and then again
just the final little rub now cut the
top off and then just open
up and look they come out like little
miniature
Smarties and there cut the little bottom
bit
off amazing
next a great tip for using spare chilies
using string tie together the stalks
then simply hang in your kitchen in just
a few weeks you'll get your very own
dried chilies great crumbled into dishes
for adding heat on demand chilies are
surprisingly versatile if you love them
in Savory dishes my tip is to try adding
them to meled chocolate ganache for
chocolate chili truffles or sprinkled
over fresh fruit like mango or
watermelon a great tip to prevent
burning sensitive skin when working with
chilies to get rid of that spice and
that heat on your fingers a little bit
of lemon squeeze a little bit of lemon
juice and that instantly gets rid of the
heat fresh lemon
juice spice up your drinks for a Mexican
twist add a dash of hot chili sauce to
beer or using cocktails to give your
drink a very different sort of
kick coming up on my Ultimate Guide to
cooking with chilies more great cooking
tips take the codon out of the fridge
literally 20 minutes before you want to
cook them so it gets up to room
temperature how to shop for the best
ingredients the smaller the chili the
hotter and an incredible spicy beef
salad to make your mouth water just
finish it with a little tablespoon of
that
[Music]
sauce this is my ultimate cooker course
100 recipes to steak your life on I'll
be showing you an amazing spicy beef
salad take a little teaspoon of your
dressing and just go over the beef but
first The Secret of cooking fantastic
food is to start with greatting
ingredients the more you know personally
about where your ingredients are from
and how they produce the better so don't
be scared ask lots of questions and love
and when it comes to chilies there's no
one better to ask than chili grower
Joanna Plum who's been farming chilies
from mild to mindblowing for over 11
years I eat chilies all the time every
single day she grows over 60 Types on
her farm and really knows her pablanos
from her
heos people think that Chili's are all
about heat actually it's about Flavor as
well some are sweet um some are aromatic
and they can be used in so many
different dishes when you go shopping
and you're looking for a chili what
should you be looking for what you want
to do is look at the chili and it needs
to be nice and firm and glossy generally
the bigger the chili the mder it's going
to be the smaller the chili the hotter
and if it's small and wrinkly like this
one is going to blow your socks off
another way to tell if a chili is hot or
not is to split it open and smell it if
it's a super hot chili it'll clear your
sinuses the heat of a chili comes from
an oil called capsacin and that is
concentrated mainly at the top of the
chili where the seeds are now when
you're cooking with a chili and you want
the flavor of the chili but not too much
of the heat start we're just using the
bottom of it as you get closer to the
seeds that chili is going to get hotter
so if you remove the seeds that also
does remove some of the heat there's
thousands of varieties out there because
they cross-pollinate very very easily
and that's why the world's hottest chili
is always changing Joanna's right with
over 200 types available all with
different flavors Aromas and of course
levels of heat it's important to buy
what you like here are my top chilies
whatever your desired kick at the mild
end pablano these are great for stuffing
have a delicate flavor and often used in
Mexican dishes starting to get hot the
jalapeno when they're green they're like
spicy bell pepper the redder they are
the sweeter they are bird's eye where
they really start to pack A- punch long
thin and pungent they're great in tie
dishes and are often green or red and at
the top end they have AO these
lantern-shaped demons have a delicious
fruity taste and they're the firecracker
of the chili World another way to use
chilies is to smoke them and to make
chipotle what it is it's just a mosquite
smoked red
jalapeno it smells fantastic you can
almost get that like Smoky bacon sort of
flavor out of it so you would use this
in anything that you would slow cook so
you're eating a chili and it's really
too hot for you the best way to get rid
of that heat is to drink some milk or a
dairy product like yogurt whatever you
do don't go for water or for beer don't
be frighten of trying new types of
chilies in your cooking experimenting
with these amazing fiery beasts is a
great excuse for getting hot-headed in
the kitchen they give you a natural high
much like when you've been exercising so
your endorphins are released and you
just feel good chilies make you happy
and they're also an
aphrodisiac
[Music]
Southeast Asian Chefs they're brilliant
at balancing the hot spiciness of chili
with sweet sour and salty
flavors if you want a new Twist on a
favorite dish spice it up with chili my
next recipe is super simple to make but
has wonderful depth and complexity of
flavors spicy beef salad chilies if you
use them confidently they can really add
a new dimension to the style of cooking
but the real trick is finding that
balance of flavors that really suits you
cuz that's the most important
part so this is the most amazing sirloin
you can see it's got that wonderful
marble for me the secret behind this is
cooking it quickly season the steaks
generously Salt and Pepper Push that
seasoning into the sirling take the
siring out the fridge literally 20
minutes before you want to cook them so
it gets up to room temperature they cook
more evenly but more importantly you can
actually season right inside the steak
this little bit of fat down here season
that as well because that is what we
want to roast and get that really nice
and rendered olive oil in a tablespoon
roll that around as it starts to smoke
in with the steaks into the pan and lay
away again into the pan and lay away if
you don't hear that noise the minute
those steaks hit the pan don't put them
in so the secret now is getting that
color on the steak turning it once and
once only and cooking it for 2 and 1/2
minutes each side what I want to do is
to get that bit of fat rendered so it
adds a lot more flavor just hold the
steak down like that and that starts to
melt the fat which makes it so much more
tender there should be no white fat left
anywhere turn them over really important
to have that steak up to room
temperature before you start cooking it
so the inside is nice and warm so he
spends less time in the pan and more
time cooling down really
important now two fingers touch it goes
in it says rare I'm happy for to be rare
Because by the time I let them rest
they're going to go back to medium rare
it'll continue cooking out onto a plate
and let them
rest
one two let's get my juices
over don't waste that really
important next the spicy dressing take
the seeds out of a chili to reduce the
heat by rubbing it in your hands and
tapping until the seeds fall out cut it
in
half and just chop
it
in garlic and chili Works brilliantly a
quick way of peeling it get your knife
and just slam it down just pops out very
very quickly in little touch of
salt
rub start going around in circles first
you'll see it
pureing nice clear that
off now we got the hea in there from the
chili and that richness from the garlic
two teaspoons of palm sugar this is
where it starts to have that nice sweet
sour
effect fish sauce fresh lime this is a
simple fresh chili dressing and it was
something I fell in love with in Vietnam
and Cambodia because it was just so
easy give that a little mix and dissolve
the sugar quick
taste wow right vegetables a great
phospher way to get super thin ribbons
of carrot is to use a veg peeler when
they're that thin they take the
vinegarette so much better and radishes
just slice them down at an
[Music]
angle lovely to give another dimension
to the salad I'm going to use a banana
shellant they are incredibly mellow
very
sweet
across just chop up the
shellant and mix that through want some
Sweetness in there now little Vine
Tomatoes slice them in half tomatoes in
chelot radish carrots and
tomatoes next Peale and sliced cucumber
chopped spring onions and Shred baby gem
lettuce and then finally get some fresh
mint it's young mint so you don't need
to take all those stalks off what you do
is hold the bunch upside down and then
take it for a little
trim and just chop that once
through you got that nice minted salad
couple of tablespoons of dressing don't
flood the salad with the dressing we can
always add but we can't take it away now
really mix that dressing in there make
sure all that chili and garlic and palm
sugar wraps around that salad
beautiful
onto the plate the steak's rested it's
now nice and medium rare that little bit
of fat we don't want to find that in the
salad just slice that off that served
its purpose it's kept that steak nice
and moist just slice going with the
grain this one more like slicing through
butter and look
inside beautiful pink you slice the beef
too thinly then it goes Stone Cold and
more importantly all the goodness runs
out of it nice thick slices
get the beef and start placing it around
the salad take a little teaspoon of your
dressing the rest of your salad sit that
on top we'll finish it off with some
toasted peanuts peanuts
in now those nuts are really toasted
nuts
on get out of the pan and just
Crush
once they've cooled down just run them
through with a knife you can hear how
crunchy they are
another texture and of the taste of the
salad and then from there
sprinkle and then finally take that just
finish it with a little tablespoon of
that sauce and there is one tasty very
well textured spicy beef
[Music]
salad
in this series I'm going to surprise you
I'm going to strip away all the
complexity and hard CFT and teach you
how to cook amazing food standing on
your head that is amazing incredibly
tender from the kitchen novice to the
buding chef I'm going to give you the
confidence the recipes and The Insider
knowledge to make you a much better cook
slice around wasting
nothing I made my name cooking some of
the world's most demanding kitchens
that's nice you make it before service
yeah in my restaurants I expect
Perfection every PL has to be worthy of
a Michelin star and every time you make
taste it as well everyday changes yeah
now I'm going to show you some simple
and accessible recipes for fantastic
food that you can cook easily at home
incredible I'll be holding you by the
hand it's getting better and better and
better teaching you everything from how
to cook on a budget to bacon real fast
food and my ultimate feast recipes this
is the only cook course you'll ever
[Music]
need Welcome to My ultimate cookery
course pack with cooking tips
information and 100 recipes to take your
life on right this is my guide to
cooking with
spice adding big gutsy flavors using
spices at the beginning of cooking and
then simply letting the dish slow cook
is a brilliant way of getting maximum
flavor with minimum
effort my first recipe melts in the
mouth and because the oven does most of
the work it's a cinch to make slow
cooked fiery lamb cooking is all about
being bold and adventurous and this dish
is exciting because it's slowly cooked
and the longer it Cooks the more
flavorsome it
becomes marinating the lamb first
chilies we're going to use a mixture of
red and green take off the
tops and just
slice
in
garlic
crushed don't worry about chopping these
ultra fine just get it in there cooking
for up to 3 hours everything sort of
Blends and almost sort of purries itself
together smoked paprika goes brilliantly
well with the chilies two teaspoons in a
touch of dried
oregano some little cumin seeds the
blend and the fragrance that they give
out is extraordinary they release a
little oil as well and helps to
tenderize Fri the lamb Touch of
salt
pepper
cinnamon that's sort of sweetens up the
lamb olive oil just a tablespoon and the
olive oil helps to sort of stick all
those wonderful spices to the lamb jump
in just start really rubbing at this
stage you can leave the lamb to marinade
for anything from half an hour to
overnight allowing the spices to really
penetrate the meat giving amazing
results when you tuck in delicious
vegetables carrots and onions and that's
it
sliced secret of slicing vegetables for
brazing is not getting too thin you
slice the onions too thin they burn you
got that horrible Char taste on that
slow brazed brazing it's just a chef's
term that means cooking in liquid on a
low heat making the meat incredibly
moist and beautifully tender so the
secret of brazing is having a really
nice thick durable pan get that nice and
hot just a touch of olive
oil lamb in hold the bone cuz you in
control then into the
[Music]
pan want that white fat to start
rendering so it'll add more fat
therefore making it a lot more
flavorsome as it
brazes
chilies
cinamon in mix that up and don't be
scared you're not burning this your sort
of searing the lamb shanks and this is
the important part right at the very
beginning we're getting the color on the
lamb which washes off as it brazes in
the oven so be generous with that color
vegetables
in wow and then couple of baes so now
you lift the lamb up and get the lamb
sat on top of the vegetables now delaz
the pan with red wine dis glazing means
that you're you're cleaning the bottom
of the pan and you're getting that
amazing flavor washed off and lifted up
into that sauce can really transform
that dish always the delays then bring
to the boil and cook for about 10
minutes to reduce the wines reduced down
by half now put the
stock bring that stock back up to the
bow and then into the oven now don't
cover it when you cover it all the
condensation comes off the lid your L
becomes gray all this effort and that
exciting spice gets washed away no lid
and in the oven for 3 hours
a slow cook on a low heat of 160° gives
the spices time to work and transform
the meat so it's mouth wateringly tender
now look at
those out on to a plate you can just see
that meat sliding down juicy and
Incredibly tender grab it by the the
shank rolling around that rich delicious
sauce look at
that and get your sauce nice beautiful
just get some mint don't chop it just
pick that fresh mint and let it snow and
there you go very spicy delicious
melting in the mouth lamb shank
amazing to get the most out of your
spices there's only one piece of kit
that you need PES and water I mean they
look fantastic and it's essential for
any good kitchen these things are so
versatile these ancient kitchen tools
are perfect for everything from pesos to
dressings and cost them around 15 quid
Ed to grind spices and you'll max out on
Flavor get perfect textures and always
be totally in control make sure you got
a nice large circumference of the
bowl so you can grind away the heavier
and the more durable they are the more
confidence it gives you when you're
pounding and there's almost a way of
confirming homemade hand pounded grab
yourself a pestil and mortar and soon
you'll be spicing with
[Music]
[Applause]
ease spices are a brilliant way to add
an extra layer and a dep of complexity
to any dish learning to use them
properly will really improve your
cooking here are three more of my super
simple spice recipes to get you
[Applause]
going first up a very easy chili and
spice white
[Music]
bait
start with the spice coating toast cesan
peppercorns and coriander seeds in a hot
dry pan to release their
[Music]
flavors add chili flakes and grind in a
pestil and water to make a fiery fine
powder combine with plain flour season
and
mix add olive oil to a hot
pan coat white bait in the spicy flour
mix then fry
fry white baits are an oily fish that
are healthy delicious and cook in
minutes once golden they're
done fantastic with garlic mayonnaise or
a simple squeeze of
[Music]
lemon ready in under 10 minutes chili
and spice white bait an easy simple
spicy
[Music]
dish my next amazingly AR atic recipe is
roasted squash
[Music]
humus start with my take on razal hanut
a classic Moroccan spice
blend in a dry pan toast Cinnamon cloves
coriander fenre and fennel
seeds then add mustard seeds and
cumin when the seeds start to pop
they're
ready add paprika and grind into a fine
powder for the hummus peel and chop
butternut
squash put on a baking tray and add
garlic simply bashed and chopped
Ginger drizzle with olive oil season and
sprinkle over the spice
mix then roast in a hot oven for half an
hour into
soft allow to cool and place in a
blender add tahini a Nutty paste made
from sesame seeds cooked chickpeas a
dash of lemon juice and a drizzle of
olive
oil flits into luxuriously creamy and
textured spices toasted for maximum
flavor amazing roasted squash
humus my final deliciously spicy dishes
curry spice sweet corn
soup
[Music]
first The Fragrant curry paste roast
coriander and cumin seeds until
aromatic then grind adding crushed
garlic chili powder turmeric and finely
chopped
[Music]
Ginger bring together with olive oil to
form a thick
paste for the soup fry finely chopped
onions in olive
oil
add the curry paste and cook to release
the
flavors add cubed potatoes chicken
stock and
season when the potato has softened stir
in cream
[Music]
corn then add whole sweet corn kernels
with some of the
juices and transfer to a blender and
Blitz until
smooth
for texture add more whole sweet corn
heat and it's ready to
[Music]
serve wonderfully satisfying coed spice
sweet corn soup that packs an amazingly
aromatic
punch three more stunning recipes that
make cooking with spice
simple incredible coming up on my
Ultimate Guide to cooking with spice
more fragrant tricks of the trade use
the back of the knife and flatten it
that removes all those little seeds off
the skin all about shopping for spice if
you're buy spices B them whole and an
incredible rice pudding to St your life
on looks like Rich aromatic lava
bubbling
away welcome back to my ultimate cookery
[Music]
course this is my guide to cooking with
spice next up my shopping guide to
buying
[Music]
spices when I buy my spice I only want
the best and it always pays to get
expert advice Burger erth has been
selling every spice Under the Sun in
London's Notting Hill for over 20 years
so she really knows what she's talking
about I love spices the smell the
texture the color spices are so very I
tell you something very very simple can
be really transformed into something
really delicious with thousands of
aromatic ingredients on her shelves if
it smells good she sells it if you buy
spices buy them whole then you can try
roast them crme them when you need them
and then they will release the essential
oils whole spices you can keep for years
give them a good
bushing wine bottle with your rolling
pin or whatever and you see there is
still Aroma and you can taste it you
smell it then it's fine there's four
main spices one is sweet one is sour one
is bitter
and one is hot this is cinnamon and that
is really a great example of a sweet
spice when you buy cinnamon quill like
this you have to check that you have
loads of different layers in here then
you can either crry this or you break a
piece off I mean this doesn't smell of
anything now but if you roll it in your
hand just quickly like this and then you
smell it again this is just unbelievable
if you have spaghetti bnes put a pinch
of cinnamon in it to bring out the
flavor Su this is one of those really
special spices sour like a lemon but it
has a salty aftertaste I use this
anywhere from marinades to salad you
haven't lived unless you tried it a
great example for a bitter spice would
actually be a turmeric this is actually
a root it grows in the ground like
ginger use it very very sparingly about
that match will actually color you a
curry or rice dish wonderful yellow Yow
watch your fingers you get really yellow
fingers from it and then we come to the
hot spices one spice that I couldn't
miss and that is Hungarian paprika
paprika is the powdery form of a bell
pepper what makes the Hungarian paprika
different is that they actually C it on
Vineyards it's sort of between the vines
it has a sweetness and it has a
sharpness to it I have it in ice cream I
have it on fish I have it everywhere
burget spot on about the power of spices
to transform dishes whether Savory or
sweet here's my quick guide to the
spices I use
most black pepper this is the spice I
couldn't do without always buy it whole
and grind yourself so you get the
freshest flavor cardamon these pods come
in green or black types and have a
fantastic Spicy Sweet Taste brilliant
for everything from curries to rice
dishes and puddings coriander these
citrusy seeds a perfect hole in pickles
or grind to use in fragrance stews and
soups cumin a Savory Spice that's
pungent and nutty it's great in
marinades for delicious Meat and Fish
then cinnamon sweetly fragrant and great
with apples or in cakes and Nutmeg warm
and spicy it's delicious in a BAL sauce
finally saffron these sweet strands
Infuse a brilliant bright red color and
are great in rotos and even though it's
more expensive than gold pinch goes a
long long way store your spices properly
and they'll last for years you keep it
airtight in a tin or in a glass chair in
your cupboard don't be scared of spices
like an after shave or a perfume you
have to select it yourself it has to fit
in with your taste and with your kitchen
supermarkets and good local shops sell
an amazing array of different spices so
there's no excuse for not being
adventurous be bold find what you like
and spice up your
cooking like go chefs I love the
challenge of transforming classic
recipes giving them a new twist to make
them modern and
vibrant to keep old dishes fresh and
exciting it's great to get
spicy my next recipe is a time honored
British classic but with the addition of
spices it's given a new lease of Life
fragrant spiced rice pudding I love
cooking with spices but you don't have
to just cook Savory dishes using
aromatics and spices across desserts
take your puddings to a completely
different
level first off our spices this is a
fresh vanilla pot fragrant and packed
full of flavor use the back of the knife
and flatten it that removes all those
little seeds off the skin of the vanilla
pod take your knife slice down the
middle and then when you open that up
the smell is incredible take the tip of
the knife and you scrape inside and look
all those seeds dying to come out that
is incredible there are thousands of
seeds still ingrained to the Pod so put
them in the casserole cardamon powerful
spicy take two little pods place your
knife on top and lightly crack them
cracking the cardamon pods helps release
all the amazing flavor cloves gives that
kind of aned flavor with a lot of depth
one 2 3 cinnamon stick snap and
in just smelling that level of fragrance
you can imagine what the rice pudding is
going to taste of turn on the heat
lightly toast those spices just a couple
of seconds and what's going to happen is
just going to sort of enhance those
spices in a way that it just draws out
an even more powerful fragrance coconut
milk
in Sugar 2 tablespoons
milk and then a couple tablespoons of
cream bring it slowly to the boil to
allow the flavors to infuse and this
rice pudding reminds me of my time in
India where I got really into that chai
tea fragrance cuz it was just so
delicious and so
comforting take a lime in the lime just
cuts through the richness of the coconut
gives it that nice little bit of acidity
goes fantastically well with the
cinnamon and that fresh vanilla nice
have a
taste now let's come up to the boil give
it a nice little clean around the
outside and in with the rice use 200 g
of pudding rice don't wash it beforehand
because the starch helps thicken the
rice pudding in the oven and just turn
that down to a light simmer and the
pudding rice starts to open up and it
absorbs all that coconut
vanilla cardamon clove and cinnamon
bring up to the bow gently and cook it
Out 3 to 5 minutes boiling it rapidly
the rice opens up and it goes into mush
so we want to keep that nice texture
that sort of fragrant rice pudding on a
gentle
simmer next a little luxury I'm going to
show you how I take this simple
delicious aromatic rice pudding to a
completely different level here's what I
do take two egg yolks separate them
now give that a really nice
whisk two nice tablespoons of mascapone
cheese whisk that into the egg
[Music]
yolks just to it's nice and smooth it's
almost like finishing the rice pudding
in a delicious custard turn off the gas
add that into the rice pudding what
happens it starts to enrich and really
thicken this rice pudding and takes it
to a completely different level the rice
is still not cooked started to go nice
and soft you can just see how it's
opening up but look it's like Rich
aromatic
lava bubbling
away finally great more citrus zest the
lime on top roasted caramelized lime
zest on top of a rice pudding is
phenomenal
then put it in the oven for 15 minutes
at 200° to finish cooking the rice and
develop the intensely aromatic
[Music]
flavors look at
that an incredibly fragrant rice pudding
how beautiful does that
look spices are a brilliant way of
helping classic dishes come alive I'll
guarantee you'll never ever have had a
rice pudding like this
[Music]
before
next my tricks of the trade and kitchen
[Music]
tips first how to zest a
lemon the important part is not to zest
any of the piff watch the following
technique and I'll show you how we've
got these original graters really
important when we use this we use the
the fine zester not the big rough one
not the one for slicing and not the
other one for grating this little one
here on a plate cuz it's always easier
to lift off on the plate than it is to
the board and the most important thing
about zesting a lemon is nice long
strokes but twisting the lemon round
every time we go down we
twist same with the orange and same with
the
lime little
tap if you go too far let me just show
you look you got that white bitter piff
that destroys the wonderful zesty flavor
and look that's what we're looking for
there this really nice vibrant lemon
zest
delicious garlic is a key ingredient in
so many spicy dishes my tip for finally
chopping and mincing is to add a pinch
of salt for abrasion which helps break
the fibers of the garlic down for a much
better
result for getting the most out of root
Ginger simply remove the skin using a
teaspoon it's easier than using a knife
and you can get around the tricky bits
or just keep the skin on and give it a
good
wash never throw out vanilla pods
there's a ton of flavor left in the skin
stick inside jars of sugar and leave to
infuse great to sprinkle on cakes
biscuits or
porridge when grinding up spices if you
have any leftover you can store it in an
airtight jar for up to 2 months great
for a spicy kick to have at your
fingertips
[Music]
Follow My ultimate cookery course
crammed with key lessons top tips and
100 recipes to stake your life on and
you'll literally be cooking yourself
into a better Chef many of these amazing
recipes are on my app please check out
the app store for
details go on get
cooking
e